Ihr könnt aufhören, mir Nachrichten zu schicken. Es ist ja gut, die Ligatour Europa, sie ist zurück. Wir sprechen jetzt über den europäischen Männerfußball. Wir blicken auf die Ligue 1, La Liga, Premier League und die Serie A und tun das mit Christian Bernhard, Chris McCarthy, Fabian Pakulat und– obacht– Jakob Haffke. Und jetzt kommt das ikonische Intro. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen in einem der Lieblingsformate von vielen von euch da draußen, zumindest laut Ergebnis unserer Hörerinnenbefragung. Deswegen hallo und herzlich willkommen. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich begrüße hier eine fast bekannte Runde. Wir haben aber ein neues Gesicht mit dabei und eine neue Stimme. Jakob Haffke ist hier. Jakob, schön, dass du in der Ligatur mit dabei bist.
Das muss ich beides nicht widersprechen, ehrlich gesagt.
Genau. Aber da gab es dann von allen Seiten unterschiedliche Aussagen zu. Bei Jonathan Rowe war relativ schnell klar, also beide Spieler wurden erstmal suspendiert. Bei Jonathan Rowe war sehr schnell klar, dass er auch gehen soll, obwohl Marseille ihn auch diesen Sommer erst fest verpflichtet hatte, nachdem er vorher von Norwich ausgeliehen war. Und da stand dann auch recht schnell fest, dass er geht zu Bologna in die Serie A für 17 Millionen. Und bei Adrian Rabiot war es erst ein bisschen hin und her. Es gab dann auch zu hören, dass de Serbi eigentlich ihn gerne behalten würde, trotz des ganzen Theaters. Weil, man muss das sagen, Rabiot war letzte Saison eigentlich der Schlüsselspieler bei Marseille im zentral-offensiven Mittelfeld. Er zählte auch zu den Führungsspielern im Kader, oder zählte zu den Führungsspielern im Kader. Aber letztendlich hat man dann nicht die Basis dafür gesehen, dass er wirklich noch weiter Bestandteil dieser Mannschaft sein kann, sodass er jetzt letztendlich auch zu Milan gegangen ist. Und das führte dann auf der anderen Seite dazu, dass man letztendlich jetzt doch einen riesigen Umbruch im Kader wieder hatte. Auch ein paar Spieler dann noch geholt hat kurz vor Schluss. Mit Pavard zum Beispiel von Inter auch einen durchaus bekannten Verteidiger. Man hat auch noch weitere Verteidiger geholt, sodass man jetzt teilweise auch mit einer komplett neuen Viererkette spielen könnte. Es sind jetzt so 7, 8 Neuzugänge je nach Spiel in der Startelf gewesen. Man hat Pierre-Emerick Aubameyang zurückgeholt aus Saudi-Arabien. Und ja, also dann am Deadline-Day noch Naif Agard geholt, O'Reilly von Brighton ausgeliehen, Vermehran von Leipzig ausgeliehen. Und also ist jetzt wieder letztendlich alles total neu. Dementsprechend durchwachsen war auch er der Saisonstart mit zwei Siegen, die relativ deutlich waren jeweils zu Hause und aber auch zwei Auswärtsniederlagen. Dann hat man ja auch in der Champions League schon bei Real Madrid sich phasenweise durchaus ganz gut geschlagen am Dienstag, auch wenn es in der Anfangsphase sehr wild aussah und man da sehr viel unter Druck geraten ist. Aber ja, man hat vielleicht so ein bisschen einfach durch diesen wahnsinnig bewegten Transfer so mal verpasst, sich zu konsolidieren und vielleicht jetzt den nächsten Schritt in Richtung Paris Saint-Germain zu gehen und ist stattdessen jetzt so, dass man eigentlich die Mannschaft noch mal komplett umgekrempelt hat und so wieder so ein bisschen von vorne anfangen muss.
Also viel, viel los bei Olympique, das kennen wir schon. Ich habe extra nachgeguckt. Milan hat schon gegen Bologna gespielt, Rabiot hat durchgespielt und Jonathan Rowe wurde eingewechselt in der 74. Minute. Christian, sind irgendwelche besonderen Vorkommnisse aus diesem Spiel zu berichten?
Ich würde es gerade sagen, das ist der Fun-Fact, den ich noch beitragen wollte. Also die zwei haben gleich wirklich beim ersten Spiel– sind sie aufeinander getroffen? Nein, es ist nichts passiert. Aber ja, ganz witzig, dass sie wirklich gleich in ihrem ersten Pflichtspiel für die Neumannschaften gleich aufeinander treffen. Ein Satz noch zu De Zerbi. Also De Zerbi hat gemeint, er kommt von der Straße und das stimmt. Er kommt aus nicht ganz einfachen Verhältnissen und er meinte, so etwas hätte er in der Fußballkabine noch nie erlebt. Also da war schon ein bisschen mehr los, weil ansonsten hätten die sich jetzt, glaube ich, auch nicht unbedingt von beiden Spielen getrennt. Und wie Jakob ja gesagt hat, gerade Rabiot ist ja für die unfassbar wichtig. Also wir waren alle nicht dabei, aber ich glaube, das war ein bisschen heftiger, was da vonstatten gegangen ist.
Das Einzige, was man aus Frankreich noch gehört hat, dass Rabiot seinen Vertrag, der zum Saisonende ausläuft, wohl nicht verlängern will oder wollte bisher, beziehungsweise halt seine Konditionen beibehalten wollte und Marseille hätte gerne einen günstigeren Vertrag. Und dann wurde das zum Beispiel auch Marseille von der Seite, von Spielerseite vorgeworfen, dass sie das jetzt nutzen würden sozusagen, um ihn rauszudrängen. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube auch eher nicht, dass das so hohe Wellen geschlagen hätte, wenn das, wenn sie sich nur kurz geschubst hätten oder so.
Na ja, vielleicht kann man festhalten, so ein wochenlanges Trainingslager fürs Team-Belting ist vielleicht nicht immer das Beste. Aber wollen wir mal nicht noch mehr reininterpretieren. Das ist der eine Chaos-Club. Und damit haben wir die perfekte Überleitung zu Manchester United. Über die wollen wir auch noch sprechen. Chris, es ist immer das gleiche mit United. Und irgendwie ist es doch immer anders. Die Frage ist nur, wie lange werden wir noch über United in dieser Art sprechen müssen? Also was sind so die aktuellen Themen, die du da noch kurz ansprechen wolltest?
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, also es geht immer irgendwie die letzten Jahre immer um Negativrekorde. Es geht nur darum, was für ein Negativrekord es diesmal ist. Eigentlich wäre das Thema natürlich auch ein Hauptthema wert. Aber wie du gerade sagst, es wiederholt sich immer wieder. Am Sonntag, chancenlos gegen Manchester City. Das siebte Mal jetzt mit 3-Ton-Unterschied gegen Pep Guardiola verloren. Schlechtes der Saisonstart seit 1992. Pokal aus gegen einen Vierteligisten. Und das Hauptthema momentan ist natürlich Amorim als Trainer. Seit Ehrenamt hat kein Team, das noch in der Premier League ist, weniger Punkte geholt. Und das ist jetzt ein Jahr. 31 Punkte in 32 Spielen, das ist schon sehr dünn. Ja, gegen City, wenn man das Spiel nicht gesehen hat und auf die Zahlen schaut, wird man denken, ganz gut verkauft, ganz gut mitgehalten. Ein Tick mehr Ballbesitz, glaube ich sogar, mehr Kontakt im Strafraum, mehr Flanken, blablabla. Aber es war ehrlich gesagt nie wirklich knapp. Uniteds Angriff war stumpf, ideenlos, hat auch nicht viel Sinn ergeben, defensive schwach und es wirkt irgendwie so, als würde City so ein bisschen die Handbremse anziehen. Man wusste, dass man einfach mehr Qualität auf dem Platz hat. Und das ist für mich so ein bisschen das Erschreckende. Klar, es ist eigentlich nie erschreckend, wenn man gegen City spielt und weniger Qualität hat. Aber wenn man sieht, dass United in den letzten fünf Jahren eigentlich genauso viel ausgegeben hat wie City, nämlich über eine Milliarde, und dann auf den Platz schaut, dann sieht man, dass da schon viel falsch gemacht wurde. Und ich habe das Gefühl, das hat sich gerade diesen Sommer fortgesetzt. Kunja, Mbembo, das sind alles, das sind super Spieler. Aber man hat halt wieder die Aktie am höchsten Punkt gekauft. Letztes Jahr haben beide statistisch gesehen sehr überperformt, haben vor allem XG überperformt und wurden dann für über 70 Millionen gekauft. Das ist nicht die klügste Investition. Cesko kann ich irgendwo verstehen, hat ein Weltklasse-Profil, wir kennen ihn aus der Bundesliga, aber dann wieder knapp 80 Millionen hinlegen. Wenn es noch andere Baustellen gibt, kann man auch ein bisschen hinterfragen. Und wenn man dann die Mannschaft sieht, da strotzt es noch an so vielen Ecken und Enden vor Durchschnitt. Casimero wirkt meistens als ob er keine Lust hat. Ogarte zerstört, kann nicht wie mit dem Ball anfangen. Hinter Defensive taucht dann immer noch ein Schor auf, ein McGuire auf, der natürlich etwas zu sehr kritisiert wird, aber trotzdem halt nicht der Top-In-Verteidiger ist. Und beste Spieler ist noch Bruno Fernandes, der auch– und jetzt will ich keine Stammtischparolen à la Roy Keane verwenden– aber der wirklich kein typischer Kapitän und Anführer ist, meiner Meinung nach. Nur meckert, nur defensiv negativ auffällt. Und ja, also es läuft viel, viel falsch. Und am bedenklichsten ist, dass es, meiner Meinung nach, bei Amorim auch falsch läuft. Er hält stur an seinem 3-4-3 fest, obwohl er nicht den Kader dazu hat. Er hat jetzt nach der Pleide gegen City gesagt, wenn ihr meine Philosophie ändern wollt, dann müsst ihr die Menschen austauschen. Klare Ansage, dass er bei seiner Sache bleibt. Und das ist für mich das Seltsamste an der gesamten Geschichte. Es taucht ein Mason Mount auf dem Flügel auf. Du hast nicht die Leute für einen 3-4-3. Und am seltsamsten ist es, wenn man sich das Spiel gegen City anschaut. Und da hat dann dein Schiedenspieler, Dorgu war das, mehr Ballkontakt in der Box gehabt als dein Stürmer und dein Zehner. Und da sieht man schon, dass da irgendwie was falsch läuft, auch systematisch. Und die haben das Ganze wieder ganz kurz runterzubringen auf einen Satz. Ich finde einfach, United hat seit Jahren immer wieder das gleiche Problem. Du hast kein übergeordnetes Konzept. Du hast überteuerte Spieler, die nicht zum Trainer passen oder umgekehrt. Und es ändern sich eigentlich nur noch die Namen.
Es ist wirklich so. Also das, was du jetzt zu Amorim erzählt hast, das war Endphase Ten Hag. Und zwar Endphase, meine ich damit, die letzten anderthalb Jahre Ten Hag, glaube ich. Kann man ungefähr so sagen. Also das ist ja völlig… Ach, Wahnsinn. Ja, United. Wir werden, glaube ich, in der Saison noch öfter über United sprechen. Da gibt es ja immer nochmal… Du hast es ja gesagt, den neuen Tiefpunkt gibt es dann. Aber wir wollen auch positive Dinge ansprechen, beziehungsweise auch mal über Teams sprechen, bei denen es gut läuft. Und damit können wir über Napoli reden. Christian, zumindest vermute ich, dass du Positives zu sagen hast bei drei Spielen, drei Siegen in der Liga und 6 zu 1 Toren.
Ja, können wir auch direkt die Brücke bauen zu Chris, auch wieder zu United. Bei Napoli spielt ein gewisser Scott Mcdominate, der das nicht so schlecht macht seit einem Jahr und zwei Monaten. Das ist ja auch so eine Geschichte. Und es geht nicht darum, Scott Mcdominate zum größten Fußballer zu machen, keine Sorge. Aber ich glaube, das war einer, der sehr an United hing, auch vielleicht ein bisschen mehr als nur als Profi. Und es ist ja vielleicht auch so eine kleine Geschichte, dass du dich da auch von solchen Leuten trennst. Und da haben wir jetzt aber die Geschichte, Scott Mcdominate und Neapol ist funktioniert wunderbar. Max, ich wollte Neapol nur jetzt ganz kurz anreisen, über die werden wir logisch in Ruhe demnächst mal reden. Erstens mal, weil wir haben ihn noch gar nicht zur Meisterschaft gratuliert. Vergangenes Saison hatten wir ja keine Sendung mehr. Also, dass Conte und Napoli Meister geworden sind, ist ja schon was Besonderes. Und jetzt eben kommt dazu, vielleicht passen die Themen ganz gut ineinander. Die Wirtschaftlichkeit von Neapol ist richtig gut in den letzten Jahren. Neapol ist mit die wirtschaftlich stärkste, der stärkste Club in Italien. Und das führt dazu, dass die einen Transfer-Sommer hatten, der für italienische Verhältnisse wirklich alle in den Schatten gestellt hat. Also alle Inters, Juves, Milans, wie sie hießen, konnten da nicht mithalten. Denn Neapol hat zu dieser bestehenden, starken Mannschaft nochmal richtig tief in die Tiefe gegangen. Angefangen Kevin De Bruyne, logischerweise. Ich glaube, ich habe alle mitbekommen, dass der mittlerweile am Vesuv kickt. Hat gleich auch schon zweimal getroffen. Wunderbar integriert. Ja, ich glaube, über die Qualität von De Bruyne muss man nicht reden. Ja, er ist nicht mehr der Jüngste. Aber ich würde mal sagen, die ersten Spiele haben gezeigt, dass er nicht zum Urlaub machen in Italien ist. Und allein dieses Plus an Übersicht, dieses Plus an Genialität, dieses Plus an Pässe im letzten Drittel, das tut Neapel sehr gut. Dazu haben sie im Sturm jetzt noch, dass sich Lukaku ja schwer verletzt hat. Der fällt jetzt erst mal noch drei Monate aus. Haben sie einfach noch mal Heulund von United sich ausgeliehen. Der trifft gleich im ersten Spiel. Der gibt ihnen logischerweise noch mal Tiefe vorne drin. Luca, den italienischen Nationalstürmer, haben sie auch schon davor dazugeholt. Und in der Abwehr haben sie mit Bojkama einen der stärksten italienischen oder Serie A-Verteidiger der letzten zwei Jahre von Bologna geholt, der einfach auch noch mal die Tiefe verstärkt. Im Tor Milinkovic-Savic eine Eins dazugeholt zu Maret. Also im Prinzip hat Konti jetzt 2, 1a, 1b. Also Napoli hat sich wirklich noch mal in der Tiefe, in der Breite qualitativ verstärkt. Und ja, dass es so ein Start passt, da ist die Euphorie noch da. Der Bräun ist wirklich alle schwärmen von seiner ruhigen Art. Der ist überhaupt nicht hingekommen, so von wegen ich bin der König, so küst mir die Füße, sondern der fügt sich wunderbar ein. Und Mc Domines weiterhin da, Alo Podcast da, Anguissa ist da, Politano di Lorenzo. Also ich wollte nur ein bisschen kurz Lust auf Napoli machen. Wie gesagt, da reden wir dann die nächsten Wochen sicher mal in Ruhe drüber. Ich glaube, das konnte Napoli auch in der Champions League in diesem Jahr. Jetzt keine Sorge, die sind jetzt logischerweise nicht plötzlich unter den ersten acht großen Namen zu nennen. Das ist mir schon klar. Aber ich glaube, das gerade konnte, hat ja auch ein bisschen eine offene Geschichte mit der Champions League, dass Napoli in dieser Saison auch international dem ein oder anderen vermeintlich größeren paar Aufgaben stellen wird.
Vielleicht ja schon heute Abend bei Manchester City. Und man wird ja auch unter anderem zu Hause gegen Eintracht Frankfurt spielen. Da kann man noch mal genauer hingucken aus deutscher Sicht.
Champions League am Donnerstag?
Ein Satz noch, da hat…
Ich will meinen Fußball.
Ey, schlimm. Ich wollte den Leverkusen-Schwerpunkt machen und bin völlig mit den Terminen durcheinander gekommen, weil die mir alle geschrieben haben, ja, ich bin bei der Champions League. So, ja, machen wir es Donnerstag. Vielleicht habe ich am Nachmittag noch Zeit. Ja, nee, da spielen die. Ach so, okay, alles klar.
Entschuldigung, Christian, du wolltest auch was sagen. Aber man kann dem UEFA-Supercomputer zumindest– sorry, ja, man kann dem UEFA-Supercomputer zumindest zugutehalten, dass er sehr viel Fußballromantik an den Tag gelegt hat, dass der Kevin de Bruyne gleich am ersten Spieltag zurück zu Manchester City auswärts führt. Ich glaube, da können wir alle davon ausgehen, dass ihm ein sehr, sehr, sehr schöner Empfang bereitet wird.
Das glaube ich allerdings auch. Also, wenn ihr schnell seid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann habt ihr das noch vor 21 Uhr am heutigen Donnerstag gehört. Ein letztes Mal nochmal kurz in die Liga. Jakob, was hast du noch mit dabei? Zwei große Namen lese ich.
Zwei große Namen und eine der positiven Überraschungen bisher in dieser Saison, das ist nämlich Lille, die nach vier Spieltagen mit zehn Punkten auf Platz 2 stehen, nur am ersten Spieltag in einem wilden Spielpunkte gelassen haben gegen Stadt-Brest, über die wir vielleicht auch in den nächsten Wochen mal sprechen müssen. Schauen wir mal, aber wir sind erstmal bei Lille und da ist der erste große Name Olivier Giroud, der natürlich auch im Sommer durchaus für Aufsehen gesorgt hat. Der ist nach 13 Jahren zurück in Frankreich, nachdem er mit Montpellier Meister geworden war und dann seinen Weg zu Chelsea, Arsenal, Milan und zuletzt dann ja nicht so erfolgreich in der MLS war. Und deswegen hatten da viele auch ein paar Fragezeichen, was diesen Transfer angeht, ob er vielleicht eher so als Maskottchen oder so kommt. Zumal wir ja auch im Serie A-Segment eben schon darüber gesprochen haben, dass ja zwei der wichtigsten Offensivspieler zu Juve gegangen sind, mit Segrova und Jonathan David. Dazu ist auch noch André Gomes gegangen, Rémi Caveya. Also und der Torwart Lucas Chevalier, der zu Paris Saint-Germain gegangen ist. Aber gerade halt in der Offensive hat man echt viele Spieler abgegeben und hat dann mit Giroud ja einen renommierten Spieler geholt. Aber es gab halt Fragen hinter seiner Leistungsfähigkeit. Die hat er allerdings bisher durchaus beeindruckend wiederlegen können, hat nach 11 Minuten im ersten Saisonspiel direkt getroffen, hat auch im zweiten Saisonspiel das entscheidende Tor zum 1-0 gegen Monaco gemacht, hat dann kurz danach noch einen Elfer verschossen, aber das hat dann keine Rolle mehr gespielt. Und was vor allem überrascht hat, dass er in beiden Spielen über 90 Minuten gespielt hat. Und man war sich jetzt nicht so sicher, ob er mit 38 noch unbedingt in der Verfassung ist, wirklich viel der Mannschaft zu geben oder ob er eher eine Option von der Bank wird, vielleicht mal 50, 60 Minuten starten kann. Bisher sieht das aber echt gut aus, was da funktioniert. Drum herum hat Lille ein echt spannendes Gerüst mit vielen jungen Offensivspielern. Matthias Fernandes Pardo ist ein Name, den man sich auf jeden Fall merken sollte, der auch schon im Sturmzentrum jetzt gespielt hat, in einem Spiel, in dem Giro da nicht gestartet ist. Hakan Haraldson ist ein ganz interessanter Isländer, der letzte Saison auch gegen Dortmund, meine ich, das Tor geschossen hat in der Champions League, als die beiden aufeinander getroffen sind. Und der zweite große Name ist einer, der eigentlich gar nicht so eine große sportliche Rolle bisher gespielt hat bei Lille, weil er jetzt mit 18 Jahren immer schon mit vielen Verletzungen auch zu kämpfen hatte. Es ist Ethan Mbappé, der kleine Bruder von Kilian. Der hat jetzt am Wochenende endlich sein erstes Ligatour auch erzielen können, hat das späte 2 zu 1 für Lille gemacht. Und ja, natürlich eine sehr schöne Geschichte für ihn, kommt auch aus der PSG-Jugend und ja, hat viel mit Verletzungen schon zu kämpfen gehabt, noch nicht so viele Minuten gesammelt und jetzt sein erstes Tor geschossen. Und man hofft so ein bisschen darauf, dass er vielleicht jetzt auch eine größere Rolle spielen kann in dieser Saison. Ist ein bisschen anderer Spielertyp als sein großer Bruder, ist kein richtiger Stürmer, ist aber durchaus auch mit Zug nach vorne, so im Mittelfeld, kann auch auf dem Flügel spielen, ist auch schnell, würde einen auch überraschen, wenn es nicht so wäre. Aber da bleibt für ihn jetzt vor allem auch erst mal zu gucken, ob er das sehr verletzungsfrei bleibt. Weil ich habe es jetzt gesagt, mit 18 hatte er schon viele, hat auch letzte Saison vier, fünf Verletzungen gehabt und da viele, viele Spiele deswegen verpasst. Aber an sich ist das wirklich sehr, sehr spannend, was Lille damit nicht ganz so großen Mitteln und trotz der ganzen Abgänge, bisher zusammenspielt. Und das kann man sich sehr gut angucken. Sie sind auch das einzige Team, was noch ungeschlagen ist neben PSG.
Allerdings, und das muss wirklich undankbar sein, Bruder von Kilian Mbappé zu sein und ihm auch noch so ähnlich zu sehen. Also es sieht ja wirklich so aus, als hätte sich Kilian eine Perücke aufgesetzt. Ich sehe es hier gerade bei einem Spielerbild. Ja, Lille, werden wir im Blick behalten, spielen ja auch in der Europa League mit. Das heißt, auch da gibt es ja so manches interessante Spiel, das man auch mal jenseits von der Liga mitverfolgen kann. Was haben wir denn in der Premier League noch, Chris, zu besprechen?
Ja, Nick Woltemade. Ich finde es aber ganz interessant zu berichten, wie er so eingeschlagen ist im ersten Spiel. Ihm ist tatsächlich etwas gelungen, was vor ihm nur Jürgen Klinsmann und Ilkay Gündogan gelungen ist, nämlich als Deutscher im ersten Spiel in der Premier League auch zu treffen. Er sollte eigentlich gar nicht spielen, aber wegen Verletzungsproblemen kam er von Anfang an direkt zu seiner Chance. Und er war am Anfang ein bisschen nervös, hat man gemerkt, ist nicht alles gelungen, aber wurde dann immer besser und hat dann auch, ich glaube, nach knapp einer halben Stunde direkt das 1-0 geschossen, spielten auch 1-0 aus. Kopfball nach einer Flanke von rechts hat sich gut gegen sein Gegner durchgesetzt und hat dann eingenickt. Und man hat dann auch gemerkt, dann kam so ein bisschen das Selbstbewusstsein dazu, die wir halt auch aus der Bundesliga kennen, hat sich oft auch fallen lassen, ein bisschen im Spielaufbau teilgenommen und auch vorne als Zielspieler überzeugt, also gut den Ball festgemacht, gut seine Mitspieler in Szene gesetzt und ja, war ein gelungener Einstand für ihn. Und Eddie Howe lubte auch seine Spielintelligenz, sein taktisches Verständnis nach dem Spiel. Und ja, heute Donnerstag darf er auch dann direkt zu Hause für Newcastle gegen Barcelona in der Champions League ran. Also eine gute Woche für ihn, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, und nach den Länderspielen kann man ihn das vielleicht auch wirklich gönnen. Das ist eine Kreutemade. Siehst du auch wieder, wie Emotionen über geplatzte Transfers, hohe Ablösesum, was auch immer da mit reinspielt. In so einen Blick auf einen Spieler, der auch erst 23 Jahre alt ist und einfach nur Fußball spielen will, mit reinspielt. Da muss man schon ein Herz aus Stein haben, um ihm das nicht zu gönnen, dass er diesen Einstand bei Newcastle haben dürfte. Danke für dieses Update und dann springen wir nochmal in die Serie A. Christian, was müssen wir da noch besprechen?
Ja, machen wir noch zum zum Rausschmeißen noch ein kleines Feel-Good. Cremonese ist einer der Aufsteiger in Italien, haben jetzt wahrscheinlich die wenigsten auf dem Zettel. Cremona, eine Stadt in Norditalien. Cremonese in den letzten 30 Jahren, jetzt erst zum dritten Mal, 33 Jahren glaube ich, zum dritten Mal in der Serie A. Also eigentlich was ganz besonderes, dass die Serie A spielen. Ein historischer Name vielleicht dazu, Gianluca Vialli, der vielleicht noch den Älteren was sagt. Der kommt aus der Cremonese-Jugend. Also da gab es früher schon immer wieder mal ein paar große Namen. Ja, die kehren in die Serie A zurück und spielen am ersten Spieltag in San Siro gegen Milan und gewinnen das Ding einfach mal 2-1. Noch nie Cremonese in San Siro gewonnen, logisch historisch. Legen dann am zweiten Spieltag gleich gegen direkten Konkurrenten, denn für Cremonese geht es logischerweise einzig und allein gegen den Abstieg. Legen gleich ein 3-2-Sieg gegen Sassuolo noch, also dem zweiten Aufsteiger. Stehen also noch zwei Spieltage mit sechs Punkten dra. Und haben jetzt am dritten Spieltag direkt das Duell wieder gegen Hellas, auch ein Abstiegskonkurrent. Auswärts einfach zwar gelitten, aber 0-0 geholt, sprich drei Spiele, sieben Punkte. Keine Sorge, ich mache Cremonese jetzt nicht zu einem Europapokal. Wie sagt man Kandidaten? Aber was man sagen kann, sie haben jetzt schon sechs Punkte Vorsprung auf den ersten Nicht-Abstiegsplatz, das nach geschmeidigen drei Spielen. Also wenn man sich daran erinnert, in der Serie A haben in den letzten Jahren manchmal schon 31, 32 Punkte gereicht, um in der Liga zu bleiben. Dann würde ich sagen, haben die ein knappes Viertel oder ein Fünftel ihrer Punkte schon eingefahren. Große Euphorie logischerweise, allein dieser San Siro Sieg und der letzte Namen. Am letzten Transfertag hat sich Krimonese Jamie Vardy geholt. Ja, Jamie Vardy spielt jetzt für Krimonese. Auch würde ich sagen, eine sehr schöne Geschichte. Ich glaube, Jamie Vardy ist auch bei vielen Fußballfans sehr positiv behaftet, hat jetzt sein Debüt gefeiert, eben gegen Hellas, ist eingewechselt worden. Und Chris, muss ich dir sagen, ich konnte Vardy jetzt die letzten Saison nicht einschätzen, was der noch so geleistet hat, aber hat mich sehr überrascht. Der hat letztes Jahr noch 9 Premier League Puden gemacht, habe ich gesehen. Also, obwohl er logischerweise nicht mehr der Jüngste ist, glaube ich, weiß der weiterhin, wo das Tor steht. Dementsprechend glaube ich, diese Geschichte, Vardy plus Krimmonese, kleiner Verein, schöner Startgeschichte, würde ich sagen, nette Feel-Good-Geschichte.
Ich hoffe, da gibt es genügend Energydrinks, weil Jamie Vardy ist dafür bekannt, sich das eine oder andere Red Bull am Tag zu gönnen. Vielleicht hält das ihn noch hier oben gescheitern.
Ja, ich glaube, die werden es sich finden lassen. Jamie Vardy hat sich ja anscheinend ein bisschen an Norditalien verliebt. Der war ja zuletzt öfter bei Cormo auch zu sehen. Da war er im Stadion auch noch bei der Aufstiegsfeier. Krimmona ist jetzt nicht so weit weg von Cormo, nicht so weit weg von Mailand, nicht so weit weg von Bologna. Also ich glaube, das ist vielleicht auch eine schöne Lebensentscheidung, dass er verstanden hat, dass es da vielleicht sich auch ganz gut geben lässt.
Immer noch mal eine meiner Lieblingsstellen aus der Miru Klose-Biografie von Ronny Reng. Miru Klose, sein ganzes Leben lang asketisch gelebt, Körperfettanteil von minus 0,5. Er wechselt in die Serie A und seine Mitspieler nehmen ihn zur Seite und sagen Miru, du musst mal später essen. Wir essen hier nicht um 19 Uhr. Du kannst nicht immer um 10 Uhr ins Bett gehen. Hier hast du mal diese Nachspeise probiert und auf einmal Körperfettanteil 9 Prozent. Und es geht ihm aber besser denn je. Also das kann passieren.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das Schöne ist, man kann ihn nur, weil man es sich gut gehen lässt. Bedeutet, es ist ja nicht Miru Klose das beste Beispiel, dass man schon trotzdem noch Leistung bringen kann. Und was für eine Leistung damals auch bei Lazio. Und ja, kann ich echt nur jedem empfehlen, dieses Buch, was du angesprochen hast. Da gibt es so wunderbare Szenen, wenn man über das Essen spricht. Ich erinnere mich noch an eine, die Tropea Zwiebel. Also die sind in Italien halt bei ganz vielen Gerichten, ist die sozusagen fester Bestandteil. Überraschenderweise hat die Klose nicht gekannt, aber er hat dann irgendwann angefangen, selbst zu kochen, die ganzen italienischen Gerichte nachzukochen, war dann immer extrem. Diese Zwiebel musste es sein, weil sonst hätte er dieses Gericht logischerweise nicht gekocht. Also ich würde sagen, ja, das ging auch mit sportlicher Leistung einher. Man kann das schon sehr gut.
Aber wirklich. Wünscht wir Jamie Vardy auch. Jungs, ich habe Hunger gekriegt. Wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Was Ähnliches, ja.
Vielen, vielen Dank euch natürlich in Abwesenheit an Fabian Pakulat. Herzlichen Dank auch an Chris McCarthy, an Jakob Haffke. Tolles Debüt. Und an Christian Bernhard. Danke euch dreien, die ihr jetzt noch hier seid. Danke. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer. Denn ihr wisst ja, alles, was wir hier im Rasenfunk machen, das ist paywall, Werbe und Sponsoren frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei voller RWE, bei blubblubhallo und bei bastianfloor auf rasenfunk.de. Da könnt ihr auf den Unterstützen-Button klicken und da erfahrt ihr, wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt. Geht auf jedem nur erdenklichen Weg und finanziert alles, was wir hier tun. Empfiehlt uns sehr gerne weiter, tragt es in die Welt hinaus. Die Ligatour geht jetzt auch mit dem europäischen Männerfußball weiter und Zweite Liga gibt es in diesem Format natürlich weiter auch. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt oder werdet gesund und bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Ciao! Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!